well the golden knights are back on home
ice this week facing the ducks once
again
sports director chris matthews joins us
live here in the studio with more on the
fast-paced golden knights team chris
yeah really christian when you think
about this team is really quick if
you're playing vegas boy you better
bring your a-game
they get up and down the ice as well as
any team in the league and it's helping
the knights jump out to the top spot in
the west
vegas gold knights are tied atop the
west division with st louis and colorado
they're coming off a sweep of the la
kings and looking sharp in the process
you know you talk about the speed of the
knights it's not just racing up and down
the ice
there's a reason why speed kills
i think that's always been a calling
card to this group
since day one before i got here
but i i think it's not just speed it's
it's how hard they work
uh in order to generate the turnovers
that lead to
to the the uh speed advantages that you
you create we we want to be a trust in
all zones so obviously when we come in
in a neutral zone we play really fast we
quick up the puck and we
we're able to catch the key the the
opponent off guard sometimes
sometimes team speed is is created by a
lot of little players it's not
necessarily
one guy just flying the zone or it's a
long pass it could be five little short
ones and
um you know that's definitely something
that we take pride in we are
vegas strong tonight at six o'clock for
our channel eight debut of face-off with
derek england
each and every monday at 6 45 we'll talk
hockey with
mr vegas strong derrick england boy
there are a lot of people
who will be interested in getting hockey
from a knights perspective kind of an
inside look so it's going to be exciting
to have
derek england join the channel 8 family